I wanted to start off by just kind of
telling you the story of Qualcomm I
assume people know the name more than
just the stadium right okay so you know
the company started with seven people my
father was one of the key people who
started it back in 1985 and the way that
I like to tell the story of the company
is about vision because the way I like
to run the company is by articulating a
vision for people to follow because that
keeps me from having to run the company
by telling everybody you do this you do
that you do this when you run it with a
vision then people figure out themselves
sort of how their projects integrate and
then when you want to innovate people
know okay well this is something in the
area that we want to go for and this
maybe is something that's sort of not
something that we want to pursue so
really try and focus in on on how the
vision of the company works and I came
up with a saying when I was running the
handset business which is to lead
through vision and not division because
one of the ways that people often try
and lead groups is by constructing
us-versus-them so it's easy to have your
team form around you if you say we're
the good guys and those people over
there are the idiots and we you know
we're gonna do great and they're not and
that what I learned from that period of
time of my life was when I did that and
I said we're great in those
infrastructure guys they don't know what
they're doing then everybody in our
company I'm sorry in my group then said
oh well I'm gonna model the leader I'm
gonna do the same thing myself and I'm
gonna say hey I'm in sales and
engineering guys they're messed up or
I'm in marketing and the finance people
are messed up and so you see people
modeled leadership and do this division
thing below so so I really focused in on
what it is that you can do that brings
people together and causes them to work
together and running with a vision is
really the key thing and the other nice
thing about vision as opposed to for
example a very detailed
plan which we do not do at Qualcomm is
then people know what hat what they
should do when they run into obstacles
so I liken it to sort of a map versus a
compass a compass tells you the
direction that you're going the map
tells you sort of what road to follow
and of course to make a map people have
already been there before so a lot of
times you want to go where people
haven't been particularly in the tech
industry so with those kind of thoughts
in mind let me just give you an outline
of the company how it started and sort
of where it where it's gone to and what
we think the future is and the first
thing that happened the first vision was
really not really a vision it was just a
set of people who came together knowing
digital communications theory and it was
people who had come from a previous
company that company had used digital
communications theory for military and
space applications because at the time
it was quite expensive and so only those
applications could actually use this
kind of computation in a device and so
forth but when Qualcomm got started the
price Moore's law drove the cost of
computation down and therefore you could
use it for commercial and consumer
applications and even then we had people
questioning whether some of these
applications could actually be done
without a van full of electronics and so
forth but we proved that it that these
things could and the very first thing
that we did was a system for messaging
the long-haul trucks we used satellite
transponders our competition actually
wanted to launch dedicated satellites
for this our guys figured out how to use
this theory to use existing TV
transponders and you can imagine the
kind of cost differential for our
company selling against somebody else
who had to support the building of that
satellite the cost of both building it
and of maintaining it and so forth
whereas we were just renting transponder
time from TV satellites that were up
there already so that was sort of the
first thing and we actually still have
that that business today
there were a whole set of things that
they thought about doing with this
digital communications theory in those
old day in the early days they didn't
actually start with a with any product
thought at all it was just the theory
they knew things would would come but
they were looking at using a particular
technology for communicating to the
satellites and one day after pitching it
my father and another engineer were
driving down the freeway from LA and
they realized that you can use it for
cellular technology and at the time the
industry was using just analog phones
which none of you know what I'm talking
about that they used to be analog and
and they were hitting what they called
the capacity brick wall they couldn't
get enough people on the system for the
amount of demand so they wanted to go
digital and the industry had decided on
a certain digital technology we came in
later with a new one and that was based
on this idea and we had what was called
the the religious wars back then and
though the echoes of those wars I would
say have mostly dissipated today but
there's still every so often you hear a
little echo somebody who still remembers
those old days and has some resentment
because one way or another on the in in
those those Wars
people's you know businesses got hurt or
their feelings got hurt or whatever it
was anyways this system was a packet
data system I actually did the speech
part of the system and it was done as
data so much like you do today when you
send voice over IP it was much like that
it wasn't IP that we were running it
over but it was all compressed and
digitized and so forth and we realized
that we could turn it into a data system
and so very early on in the early 90s we
put the internet protocols into the
phone and and so the next thing that we
did was really focus in on wireless
internet being a more profound impact on
the world than the wired Internet and
people didn't believe that for a very
long time you know the operators when we
tried to put the wireless internet into
the phone they said people want to talk
on it you know what's the inner
what the value of that and when we
finally got them to put data in it they
said you know it has to be like a
dial-up modem and we said fine we'll put
the internet of protocols in the middle
and we'll put this other stuff on the
outside that makes it look like what you
want the next year we pulled that stuff
out and just had a browser connecting
directly into the internet and we were
sort of off and running but that was the
next big thing for us was really going
and pushing that and the nice thing
about that was we didn't really have to
strategize that much to figure out what
was good for the company and I would
argue too that many companies that you
see that are successful in fast moving
are able to do that because they don't
have to my nutri optimize their strategy
in our case we knew that anything that
drove wireless data was good for us
because we did wireless data better than
anybody else much like Google today
knows that anything they do that drives
search is good for them because that's
where their money flows in from and so I
have seen the you know many companies in
the in the wireless industry where they
got into a position where an opportunity
presented itself and they sat around for
a long time trying to figure out well if
I optimize this or that I'll have a
little bit of an advantage here or there
and by the time they actually decided to
move the somebody else had already
gotten them before them gotten there
before them and the opportunity was gone
so so you got a you know you've got to
be you got to be ready to move and if
you have something which you know is the
fundamental thing that you can use
that's that's you know a wonderful place
to be and we were in that place okay so
after we started working on the internet
we said okay what are you gonna use it
for on the phone and this was back at a
time when people were saying things like
oh you're putting too many features into
the phone what do I need to you know all
this stuff for but we had a fundamental
belief that the phone would turn out the
way that it is which is it's a personal
device not just for communication but
for entertainment and productivity and
all these other kinds of things so very
long time ago we started putting in
microprocessor technology you know we
were known just as a radio company and
now we were putting microprocessor
technology and graphics and sensors and
you know there was a time when when
phones did not have cameras or color
screens and we had to actually fight to
get the operators to agree that those
kinds of things should go in we put GPS
and she
pS actually got into the phone not for
location services but simply because the
government wanted to know when you made
a 911 call from your cellular phone
where you were to go help you out and by
the way the government was incredibly
poor at implementing their side of the
system the phones all had the capability
far before the the service centers that
the government ran could actually take
that data and get you know somebody to
you in the right place in any case that
was the early impetus for getting GPS
and I'll tell you the operators at that
time were so worried about privacy
implications for many many years they
didn't allow location-based applications
on the on the phone anyways during that
time this was a time when we built our
software platform an app downloading
platform we built the first smartphone
with the palm operating system running
on and all these kinds of early
innovations that we now see as you know
fundamentally part of the wireless
internet so today everybody gets this
they all realize that the phone is this
thing that's so personal for us they
realize that you want to put more and
more stuff into the phone and so the
vision now has evolved and the vision
for us right now is one that we call
digital Sixth Sense which is there is
stuff in the world around us there's
content there are services there are
certainly people that we want to
interact with and there's cyberspace
information associated with those people
or locations or things and we actually
want to be able to detect when we're in
proximity of something that might be of
interest to us and control it and so you
may have heard of the Internet of Things
where all things around us are going to
be connected
we call it the internet of everything
because we believe that it's you know
it's basically going to be fundamental
that things will be connected in the
world around you and the phone is gonna
sit there it's going to be your way of
detecting what's around you and
controlling what's around you and
authenticating yourself to things and
places and people and so this is kind of
the next area that we're we're working
on and and the numbers are pretty
staggering there's estimates that there
will be 24 billion connected
things by 2020 half of those will be
cellular connected others will be
connected in various different ways but
but that's sort of the vision that we're
working on right now and you can see the
early stages of these things you know
I'm wearing a Nike FuelBand this
Bluetooth to my device and uploads my
activity levels but you can imagine
where that will head in the future take
healthcare in particular we're working
with a researcher that has a device
that's small enough that it will get
injected into your arm and two weeks
ahead of time it can detect certain
things flowing your blood to tell you
that you're going to have a heart attack
so imagine in the future your phone will
ring and tell you to go to the doctor
and get checked up because you're gonna
have a heart attack and and people say
oh nobody's going to will nobody's going
to be willing to have technology put
inside their body but in fact that
happens already today there's been
studies on pacemakers that a connected
pacemaker has 50% lower mortality rate
than a disconnected pacemaker and so
there is a reason that we will have
mobile health and you heard I'm doing
this ambassadorship is that actually
interestingly enough a program started
by Desmond Tutu and he was interested in
mobile health and health because in the
developing world there's just not enough
access to health care and with 6.6
billion mobile connections the mobile
phone is the biggest technology platform
so he understood that making use of sort
of mankind's biggest platform was his
way of providing health care to people
and we we recognized that ourselves by
the way we've done a lot of work in the
mobile health area one of the things
that you may or may not know is that
there's a 10 million dollar XPrize do
you guys know the XPrize yes no I know
the XPrize ok for those who don't know
the XPrize what actually the first
XPrize was they launched a spacecraft a
reusable spacecraft and had to be able
to carry three people up to us
altitude come down and be reused within
a certain period of time and that took a
long time to win and now that technology
is being used by Virgin Galactic and
they're gonna start commercial space
flights the one that we did was around
the tricorder from Star Trek you know
the box where you wave it over people
and it tells them you know how healthy
they are and the thing is that that
technology is available basically today
so there are sensors that are being done
by people there is software and decision
support systems that are being done by
people and what we wanted to do was
create a moment much like the iPhone
created for the mobile internet when all
of a sudden it became very mainstream
we wanted to create that for mobile
health and so our thought is if we can
get groups of people to come together
these global teams to come together and
create something and the idea is that
this box for less than 5 pound box will
be able to diagnose 15 diseases better
than a panel of doctors and we're gonna
have this prize competition in basically
three years from now let's see the
number of teams that are working on it
right now is 285 teams from from 35
countries so it's really a global
competition and we'll see
I think mobile health really take off
and all of these things are consistent
with this vision so I have a group of
people that are in the company and they
came up with the idea for a product in
the mobile health space and it wasn't
because I went and said to them here
this is the area that you have to go
work in and because this is in our
strategic plan as the thing that we're
doing right now was because they
understood that they we wanted to find
innovation within that area and they
thought around they talked with
customers they worked through a bunch of
different projects and they came up with
that one so I think you know the this
notion of vision LED and also the other
notion that I that I said I mentioned
around the XPrize is the notion of
catalyzing other people to do stuff and
so we spent a lot of time trying to look
for places where we're not necessarily
going to deliver the things too
the customer the end customer but if we
start off with some project other people
will see it and then they'll jump on
board and drive things and the
smartphone is a perfect example of that
the fact that we're sitting in the
position that we're sitting in right now
able to supply into the vast majority of
smartphones is because we helped create
that industry and then when it really
took off we were there with the right
products to go into it maybe maybe to go
from kind of the vision to what what
that actually then turned into in in
terms of the companies so this is a
global you know you guys are looking at
global business we are clearly a global
business right now we have a hundred and
eighty eight locations around the world
78 of those locations are in the United
States we have about 27,000 employees
about one-third of them are are outside
the United States two-thirds in the
United States about 12,000 in San Diego
where we started 65 percent of our
employees are engineers we do a huge
internship program will do will have 12
1200 interns at Qualcomm this summer and
that's the main way that we hire outside
of all right and by the way not just for
engineers but also for business people
too that's the main way that we hire out
of colleges is have people come and do
internships you get to know us we get to
know you that that actually works out
extremely well the other thing that's
interesting is we have a hundred and
eighteen different nationalities in our
workforce right now so it is a very very
global workforce and you say okay well
how do you manage such a global
workforce and and the truth of the
matter is we work very hard at it we for
a long time we had an office or first
office was actually in Israel
international officers in Israel and for
probably 10 years every year we thought
about shutting it down because it just
we didn't get the engagement and we had
to figure out how to make this work and
that the lessons that we learned there
the best thing that we learned was that
if you're going to have an office
outside
a remote office the best thing you need
to do is make sure that it has a mission
because once it has a mission it has set
of projects that are continuing they can
build sort of deep professionalism
around certain areas if you act if you
leave a global office to be sort of a
job shop then people are just in and out
on different projects all the time they
don't build up the levels of trust that
you need with the main organization in
San Diego and and therefore it doesn't
work and so you just kind of you you
lack the ability to measure achievement
in a global office so we've we've
organized ourselves that way if you look
around actually not just internationally
but all of our offices have some mission
that they're associated with or some set
of missions and that's actually created
the linkages both at the very top and
all the way down through the
organization to make a very high
bandwidth connection and the reason why
that's important is that the way that
information flows at Qualcomm is very
non hierarchical it's quite unstructured
we rely very heavily on email we've
always been an email culture and
information doesn't necessarily even
flow to me as the CEO if not if I'm not
providing value in a conversation in a
thread on some topic and so when you
talk about a global office the ability
to build the trust and the thought that
okay this person needs to be looped into
this conversation has to happen only
through building the trust and by the
way it's also made it quite difficult
for people to come in from the outside
if they come in from an organisation
that has a very hierarchical mind set it
they always bounce off and the
antibodies form and those people end up
not being successful at the company and
so it's really quite important for
people who come into the organization to
be very open very willing to accept
input from a lot of diverse sources to
go build their networks up within the
company and in fact when we do our
onboarding for executives or board
members or new employees I mean that
that that part of it is stressed highly
and the reason why that works so well is
that in an innovation
in a very fast-paced organization you
just have to be very flexible and be
able to organize and reorganize around
the people who have the knowledge to go
solve the issues and that has worked
extremely extremely well for us people
like the culture um and we've been on
the best places to work list for 15
years in a row and and and I think you
know this this notion that the company
is we don't have big facilities we don't
have big factories we actually are all
about people and their ideas in fact
even in our chipset business we don't
actually make the chips we have what's
called Fabolous and so some other
manufacturer makes the chips for us and
so what our engineers are creating are
virtual things they are the designs of
the chips as opposed to the
manufacturing of a thing and in our
licensing business people are creating
ideas and that that's what we're
licensing out and these two businesses
are very synergistic with each other -
if you're in the licensing business what
it means is that we can be very early in
a new technology area so we can create
some new thing we can build an
intellectual property portfolio for that
but what what it also means is that if
that idea doesn't get out into the
market it's not valuable so the chip
business I often look at as a
distribution channel for ideas actually
and the licensing business is the thing
that allows the chip business to have
access to new technology early because
the licensing business is creating and
and so it's very synergistic between the
two businesses and then what what we
really have as an important facet of the
company is that because we don't sell
directly to the end-user anymore it's
all about our relationships with our
partners along the value chain and so in
fact when I took over in 2005 the first
All Hands meeting that I had I said to
the
you know we're known as a great
innovator we're known that we hit our
schedule and meet our performance
targets so we execute well but going
back to that story about the religious
wars we weren't really known as a great
partner
so I said to people that the fundamental
values of the company
are going to be innovation execution and
partnership and then the question is how
do you get your products to market
because we're in a technology industry
where in order to not be commoditized we
need to get the next new technology to
market as fast as possible
and so we've created a lot of different
strategies to get partners to want to
take the next new technology and as an
example you know these days because
we're in a very readership position with
the chipsets we now have our customers
whether they're large companies or
smaller companies competing to be the
first one to launch a new phone with our
latest chips and we don't try and play
kingmaker we say okay who is it that's
going to put the set of resources and
has a demonstrated ability to execute to
get that out to market because the
strategy that we're using there is kind
of a leap frogging strategy it's that if
somebody wants to hold back and they
don't go with the next new technology
but somebody else gets ahead of them
then everybody's forced to follow and so
this notion of finding the rabbets
finding the leaders that will get out
there take the newest technology bring
it into the market drive it very hard
and then get everybody else to follow
it's been one that's that's worked out
incredibly well for us and if you look
at kind of a way that the company's
grown so I'll go back to say fiscal 10
through this year the the business is
gone revenue side 11 billion 15 billion
19 billion in this year will go 24 and a
half billion and we've become the number
one company and wireless chips we become
the number one fabless company were
actually by revenues the number three
semiconductor company now behind only
Intel and Samsung
so the strategy has worked extremely
well and another thing that we we
decided to focus on was just being as
bra
we possibly could so one of the
competitive advantages that we have is
not only are we driving the technology
very rapidly but we have enough scale so
that when a customer is trying to get
their phone into acceptance from a
wireless operator we can send a huge
team of people to go knock the last few
bugs out and because we have you know
hundreds there's I think right now we
have 475 designs different designs that
are in work at different companies right
now I mean not released yet not
announced yet but just the the next new
things so you can imagine there's just a
huge set of demands on our time to bring
resources there and so that notion of
being the best partner at scale is
really one of the key competitive
differentiators for us other let me talk
a little bit about kind of what happened
when I when I took over so right when I
took over in oh five a lot of
interesting things were happened they
were not very pleasant for me right away
we had attacks by a bunch of competitors
so I I talked about the wars and
resentment and so essentially companies
Ericsson and Nokia sort of the big
European telecom companies Texas
Instruments Broadcom Panasonic NEC a
number of different companies all sued
us globally so I we had been this
company in San Diego we're kind of
working away we build our technology and
all of a sudden I took over and within
you know months we had a global war and
it was not just lawsuits it was also
regulatory action so the European Union
got involved looking to see are we
dominant Korea looked at us Japan looked
US and just a whole range of things and
at the time one of the things that we
looked at to try and deal with that was
whether we would split the company into
two pieces and so we had this notion do
we need to separate the chip business
and the licensing business so that
people can't use leverage on the chip
business as a way to drive the licensing
business down and that was actually a
fundamental probably the biggest
question that I dealt with in the entire
time that I'd
and CEO and we got very close we got
down to the final board meeting we're
just about to separate out we had
already chosen you know who was gonna be
the next CEO and so forth and and I in
the end I decided not to do it and it
was because of what I said earlier about
the synergies between the chip business
and the licensing business but that was
a that decision in that notion that we
might spin or not spin was something
that actually caused a fracture in the
company which has which has healed now
but for a very very long time you had
those silos that kind of that us versus
meant them mentality that I talked about
earlier and really had to really had to
work on on fixing that so now the kinds
of things that we do to try and and have
strategies to win we have this notion of
scale and we have this synergy between
the businesses that I talked about the
other things that we really focus on
also are the notion of integrating more
capabilities into the chipset and so
like I said earlier we were known as a
radio company but now we actually had
the best microprocessors for mobile we
have the best graphics technology for
mobile connectivity sensors we have a
wide range of technologies and now when
people have to compete against our chips
they have to win on all those different
vectors in order to do that and now it's
sort of an arms race strategy we're big
enough that we can invest a huge amount
in R&D four billion dollars in R&D last
year and we focus it in on adding new
then what's the next new functionality
and even so we clearly can do that at
the high end but even at the very low
end of the market where we're fighting
in a much more commoditized space we
continue to bring new technology down
into the low end of the market in order
to compete against the the companies
that are trying to compete with us there
so so the notion of integration the
notion of arms race we also try and have
a very broad portfolio and the idea
there is that if you're a company that's
going to try and compete with us and win
at some other at some handset
manufacturer you got you come in with
one chip
you might win one product you might win
a product in a certain tier but because
there's so much pressure on cost and the
cost of developing new products there's
so much pressure on being the first
market with the next a new product that
really doesn't work the companies don't
want to have all sorts of different
platforms to try and develop on and so
what we try and do is make sure that we
fill all the different spaces all the
gaps in there in the or sorry all the
tears in their roadmap with the chip
that's focused on that so we have a
broad number of chips wide portfolio and
that way we're protected against
somebody trying to come in and attack us
using point solutions and then then the
final thing is really this notion of
expanding the battlefield and so we do
things where we try and bring the next
new technology whether it's a new radio
technology whether it's a new micro
process or a graphics technology but
also we do these things according to the
visions that I talked about how do you
how do you interface with the world
around us how can we do that in an
efficient manner how can we do that
without burning out the battery of the
phone so that when you're walking around
you're always looking to see what
services or content or people that are
around you that you might want to
interact with your phone's not just
dying like you know halfway through the
day because of that so this notion of
you know of all these different kinds of
technologies that we can put into the
chip expands a battlefield and one
recent example was there's a new
technology of 4G technology coming out
in governments everywhere in the world
are trying to figure out what's the new
spectrum that I can put this technology
and they're all coming up with different
answers and so what happens then is that
in different countries you take your
phone and it may not even be able to
connect on 4G because there's you know
it's just running at a different part of
the frequency spectrum like a different
radio station so we built a technology
that will solve that problem and it's a
very integrated technology and low cost
technology that took us eight years to
do and now our competitors have to
compete with that that's another area
where we've just created a new vector
upon which they have to compete with us
so
we're always trying to look for the next
new thing to keep them behind us and it
really comes down to the innovation and
so maybe I'll close to open up with the
question just quickly on how the
innovation gets done the thing like that
radio chip that came out of a
traditional business unit just doing
their normal okay how do we how do we
build more content in the phone how do
we improve this issue that we see coming
from our customers so that's a normal
sort of process you have very specific
kind of gate processes for that we also
have corporate R&D so a big engineering
organization that they're also have
fairly formalized processes they do sort
of the next new technology and one great
thing that's just come out from there is
this notion what we call supplemental
downlink where you can you know most of
the time you're downloading stuff on
your phone and that's the from the
network to your phone is what's
congested and we came up with a way very
simply and cheaply to allow you to add
more ways to send information down
rather than up and that's something
that's differentiated our our chips
that's from from the competition but
there's a wide range of technologies in
there another area is we have a thing
called Qualcomm labs which is
organization where we try and focus in
on services and products and so we have
a product called Qualcomm life 2 net and
it's a hub that connects medical
equipment to a database and mashups can
be done and so forth and that that came
out of that but we also have these
things where we have very wide funnels
where we try and let everybody in the
organization know that they can
participate in creating new ideas their
ideas can get into the market and I tell
people then with the size of Qualcomm
with the number of chips that we ship
you know over half a billion chips in a
year your ideas can affect people's
lives very rapidly and so everybody in
the organization is incentivized to come
up with new ideas and so we have this
augmented reality technology where you
composite virtual objects into your
scene of the real world in in your phone
and that came from an internal ideas
competent
and it didn't come out of engineering
came out from a guy out of finance and
now that technology right now there's
35,000 sorry 3,500 apps in the App Store
and 55,000 developers globally in it
that didn't come exactly the way he had
proposed it it got morphed along the way
but but there is an opportunity for
everybody in the company to innovate and
that's I think the thing that you know
really is the core of our competitive
advantage so maybe I'll stop talking and
just give you guys a chance to ask some
questions what area of technology do you
worry about that might be disruptive to
to your industry I mean we're always
worried about things that might disrupt
the wireless operators business models
so you know more of our money comes from
licensed band technology you know the
things that like a what a Verizon an
AT&T t-mobile Sprint those guys run so
we always have watched Wi-Fi as an
example but we actually now know based
on some new work that we've done that if
you're trying to get mass volumes of
data through and we're working on a idea
called a thousand acts which is getting
a thousand times more data through the
system at a thousand times lower cost
you know the the issue with with Wi-Fi
is that these things don't coordinate
and they actually interfere with each
other and so we looked at Wi-Fi as a
competition in addition to a
complementary technology obviously
because it is complementary but we
worried could it be competitive in the
future we said okay what are its issues
and let's go solve those issues in the
license band technology now what we want
to do is adopt also the good sides of
life I like people feel like hey I'm
using Wi-Fi I can have unlimited data I
don't need to worry about it we're gonna
solve that problem by driving the cost
per bit delivered over the network on
the cellular networks down very
dramatically thousand times so you know
we'll try and solve those problems give
you what you want to give the same
reliability and the scalability that you
get out of licensed technologies that's
probably the probably the top thing that
we we think about boat you know we it's
so broad we think about you know
integrated circuit technology all the
way down at the bottom of the
process all the way up to sort of
applications and and so forth my name is
Ambrose Jana and the first year MBA here
and I worked at SMI C in Shanghai before
coming to the GSB looking into the
future I'd like to hear what technology
trends are exciting for you and for
Qualcomm okay so the things that we you
know we have a we have a certain set of
growth opportunities ahead of us right
now so we're we see obviously the
smartphone revolution as being one
that's here and now it's got you know a
lot of legs to it we see the opportunity
to extend that into the emerging markets
so growth in the emerging markets is
going to be dramatic and there it's
actually a technology issue you've got
to drive the cost down very dramatically
so that the price points are affordable
for for people at the bottom of the
pyramid then we kind of look out and we
say okay what are the next set of things
and we're a little bit in the middle of
the next one which is just redefining
what computing is so tablets you know
it's I still see people with laptops but
I think increasingly you will see fewer
and fewer people carrying around laptops
I actually don't carry a laptop anymore
myself and so I think you know that
redefining of the way that computing
goes and then by extension redefining of
entertainment and the connected home and
so the connected enterprise connected
home and then this thousand acts the
notion that we're actually going to
extend the network and make the cellular
system deployed more like Wi-Fi and then
once you do that you can imagine that
those things can actually be some sort
of a technology to allow you to interact
with things in your house we can put all
sorts of other things in that as a
gateway technology so that's that's
pretty exciting and then as I said this
notion of the of the digital Sixth Sense
so this idea that we'll have
connectivity and all the things in the
world around us that the phone will act
or whatever device might be a watch
might be glass you know might however it
is whatever device it is that you're
using as your main way to interact will
sort of allow you to know what's around
you
one of the technologies that were
working on they're making a big
investment in is on the display side
where right now you know it's it's
bizarre because normally you put your
phone down on the table and you see a
dead screen and you think well that
things off but really this thing is on
the network it's sucking down my email
it's updating my calendar my contact my
facebook my whatever it you know it's
doing all that stuff but it just looks
like it's dead and wouldn't it be nice
if it was just on and it could alert me
when things were around me and you can
see how that sort of plays into this
notion that I said that the phone will
tell you when their services or content
or other things that are around you that
you might want to interact with so the
idea of a continuous interaction model
with always-on screens and other sorts
of user interface that might talk to you
those things I think are exciting and
then if I look kind of in the five to
ten year time frame because it's gonna
really take those kinds of time frames
you know this is an early indicator of
mobile health but I think mobile health
will absolutely change the way health
care is done it will solve a problem
which is a incredibly bad problem which
is health care is basically bankrupting
the developed world and it's not
available enough in the developing world
and so we're gonna solve those issues as
well in your vision based approach with
Qualcomm how do you think about focus
while having that very broad portfolio
so what so it's it does allow us to
focus and in various organizations there
are different mechanisms that that have
gate processes for example so a business
unit ideas will come up and then they
have to go through sort of a winnowing
process and for things that are
relatively small we allow sort of more
bubbles to be bubbling in the pot and
when they get bigger and bigger then you
get in and you and you you're much more
specific about okay this one we will
continue this one will allocate more
resources to this one you can continue
won't have so many resources this other
one what stopped that one or put it on
the shelf and so generally you can see
projects in the company by the number of
people they attract so certain things
are just done naturally but the ones
that are just random and kind of out
there and floating
around if it's a somebody with an idea
in the company they're working on it
then if it's a good one then their
friends come work on it and after a
little while you see there's a set of
people working on and then it can be
managed - so all the way from things
that are very formalized down to just
ideas that are randomly bubbling up we
we can actually get in and then then
manage those processes and that actually
worked quite well I'm just going with
whoever gets the microphone so so as a
leader of a large organization that's so
complex
my question is especially when you reach
times of conflict like in oh six when
you took over what what do you how did
you go about creating channels of
information that you could rely on and
and furthermore of creating a group of
advisers who you could trust and who you
could bounce ideas off in order to make
these types of decisions so a lot of the
people in the senior team have been
together for a very long time so we're
we're actually all friends remember this
the the executive vice president said
Qualcomm hang out together outside of
work even and we like each other and so
we don't have the political issues that
you have in certain and other
organizations we've seen you know with
companies that we work with so people
actually don't generally look at if
something's going wrong or something
needs to be done and somebody else comes
in and helps out it's not seen as oh
you're stepping into my turf trying to
steal my glory it's like Thanks
I needed some help I was overload and
and so just having that culture right
off causes information to flow and it
goes along with what I said about the
the networks and so forth that people
create these networks and information
flows to where people are adding value I
did have to change out my legal team and
we set the top-level because in the
beginning we were very good we're not we
people have this impression that
Qualcomm was a litigation company and we
never were we were a licensing company
there were times when we had some
litigation but it was generally a onesie
twosie kind of thing and there it was
almost like the kid with a soccer near
the soccer team swarming to the soccer
ball so if you could focus on one or two
things you could do a great job when it
became a
worldwide thing that didn't work and we
had to have more structure we actually
brought in somebody from the outside who
had been at IBM for a long time
went to Apple for a short stint and then
came to work with us and he had a lot of
outside relationships that he could then
bring to us and so it was a combination
of depending on sort of the group of
people we're just pulling together and
focus you know getting focused and
bringing a few specific people in from
the outside so essentially as you
pointed out yourself you know not just
companies but the world is a very siloed
place
how does Qualcomm go about basically
getting its ideas from the rest of the
world finding those best ideas looking
at trends because technology is now
developed all over the place so one of
the one thing is we you know we have so
many employees and they talk with their
friends and they are on the internet you
know so we picked stuff up that way some
of the more formal methods is we have a
venture fund the venture fund is
actually under the chief technology
officer not under finance not under the
Treasury function and its primary goal
is to be a sensor and so they actually
are out there looking for companies that
we might want to partner with and then
have you know build build technology
with or integrate their capabilities
into our products but you know it comes
from a lot of things and I think the key
lesson is you've got to be willing to
accept diverse inputs I just feel that
incredibly strongly that if you allow
yourself to get locked into one way of
thinking you only listen to the people
around you you're gonna blow it because
you're just gonna you're gonna miss the
thing that's coming in from the side and
one of the one of the things I always
tell people is like if if you hear
somebody tell you something that
everybody believes what the conventional
wisdom is go examine the assumptions
that underlie that conventional wisdom
because they're almost always wrong and
there's a way to go create something new
and cdma was a great example of that
where everybody thought you had to do
one kind of technology you did another
the Omni tracks example that I said
early on where people thought you had to
launch your own satellite
but you didn't you could do it another
way when we did the brew software
download system people thought that you
had to build a sandbox to sandbox the
applications and and keep them away from
the hardware and we said no we can sign
the applications and authenticate them
so I mean all along the history of the
company we've we've done things where we
kind of look around and say ok what's
the world doing how do we create a open
space for ourselves by examining the
assumptions - so we we do that you know
we gather information almost as a way to
stimulate what could be done differently
Stanford alumni also San Diego native so
thank you for what you and your family
have done for the city well my question
is about your reference to Qualcomm
Stadium and I know that the the term of
that deal expires in 2017 so I'm just
curious if you were to do another 20
year deal hypothetically finances aside
what would some of the technologies that
you've talked about today bring to life
in a consumer rich environment like a
stadium some of the sixth sense you
talked about was really interesting yes
so we're actually doing some work
already we've made an announcement with
Major League Baseball where we're going
in and helping them optimize the
stadium's part of that will be some of
this thousand x idea we're gonna have a
lot of small cells all distributed
around and manage the interference and
just increase the capacity in the
network but we have this this context
awareness technology called gimbal it's
being used right now for the Star Trek
app in case any of you guys care but it
basically it's the idea of when you go
to certain locations you win points
you've finished missions or whatever and
you can imagine this will get used in a
stadium environment to tell you where to
go to you know if you want to order
things or give you some information
about what's going on around you or even
give you information about the sporting
event we're also working on radio
technologies that will at a much lower
power allow you to discover things in
the environment around you and much much
more simply and we have a technology
called alljoyn which is a open source
project where all we're trying to do is
create a common way for all this
internet of everything to talk to
each other and so you may come into an
environment and something will say okay
you're sitting at this seat you have the
ability to order here or you can pull up
this content about the game or you can
pull up this camera angle I mean you can
imagine a million different things that
might happen or I walk in and I'm a I'm
a season ticket holder so I get
something special for that or I gave my
tickets to somebody else that day and
therefore they can you know benefit from
what I you know what I was getting and
so all sorts of different ideas about
how we can do that I think we'll
definitely see that in in addition to I
mean I don't it's going to be hard to
get a new stadium building in San Diego
because of the politics but I'm also
involved in this thing for the
Sacramento Kings so and we'll be
building a new arena in Sacramento and
I'm hopeful hopeful that we'll put some
pretty cool technology in there that
really make a great fan experience yeah
well thanks for coming I have a question
for you I I do feel that you have a lot
of enthusiasm for this in the end of
things and the sixth sense what one
thing if you can share with us a little
bit more color on how quickly do you
think the ecosystem is developing you
know what momentum we see an ecosystem
and if you can share what you see as you
know the killer app you know that would
kickstart this whole thing thank you
yeah yeah I think there's gonna be a
bunch of different killer apps I mean
some of them will come early from one
example is there's a big push and
consumer electronics around smart TV and
to me a Smart TV was this idea that
you're gonna run smartphone apps on your
TV which I always thought was somewhat
lame and I didn't believe in it that
much but one of the things I showed at
my CES keynote is something that I do
believe in which is the idea that I will
have my tablet or my smartphone my
friends will have their tablet
smartphone and the screen that we use
because they're getting to be large and
high resolution that will actually be
the communal space so we'll be watching
the broadcast and we'll post different
things that we're interested in so you
have both a private and a public aspect
so that's sort of an entertainment
aspect of working with
but you can imagine the business aspect
of it I come into and into a meeting
with other people and instead of passing
out powerpoints everybody has a set of
slides on their device and I want to
show you know we're talking and I want
to show this slide on the screen and I
posted it and it goes up on the screen
because I'm talking to the projector but
it also can get sent around to everybody
else's devices so that they can have it
they can comment on it they might be
able to edit it so the notion in real
time creating ad hoc groups I think will
be another interesting one one that
we're having a lot of success with right
now which is in the telematics area so
getting things built into cars we you
know making the car connected but today
when you get in your car with your phone
you have to pair the Bluetooth up and
you get in and out of the car and you're
on a call and the Bluetooth doesn't know
to drop when you get out of the call car
and you can't really it's not that easy
to get your content in and out I mean if
you have a iPhone or iPod and you you
have a phone I'm sorry a car with the
plug it's a little bit easier but you
still don't have a very rich environment
to interact with it and so what's gonna
happen in the future is you're gonna get
in the car the phone's gonna say to the
car this is Paul Jacobs here's his
preferences here's the content that he
has the cars gonna say to my phone this
is the screen here's the speakers here's
the buttons here's the other things that
you can control in the car but even
better when my friends get into the car
they're also going to be authorized then
to send their content to the stereo
system so we can all have a you know a
jukebox together or something and say
you know so all sorts of interesting
things where we'll be able to change the
way the car works we're gonna do the
same thing in retail so it's giving a
you know some of the examples in context
or sports but you can imagine walking in
you can get loyalty application you
can't offers and things like that and
we're the technology that we're building
which I like a lot is one which
preserves anonymity so instead of
walking into a store and saying Paul
Jacobs just walked into the store what
do you know about Paul Jacobs to send
him information what will happen is the
store will know or my phone will know
that I walked into a store
and not necessarily that I will then
tell the story it's me it may be that it
will just say this is a person with
these kinds of characteristics do you
want to give an offer to that person and
I'll have opted into it and the
technology actually came out of you know
trying to figure out how to track lost
children and it's sort of an evolution
of that into more of a commercial space
but I think that technologies can be
really interesting because back in the
days when we first cheap put GPS into
the phone people used to say to me
things like oh well when you're walking
by McDonald's McDonald's gonna send you
a coupon I'm like I don't want
McDonald's knowing where I am at all
times so that just when I happen to walk
by they can send me a coupon to me it's
much more interesting that McDonald's
might be broadcasting something that my
phone will walk through see that that
offer is there if I actually care about
McDonald's it will alert me buzz hear
hear hear you know something will happen
that I'll know and then I can react to
it if I'm not interested those bits just
get dropped on the floor I walk by
nobody knows anything you know they
don't know any anything that I went by
or anything so those kind of
technologies are gonna roll out and in
the very near future as well and give us
this opportunity to interact with the
world around us in a much more rich
fashion okay you told me that I need to
stop at one and it's just past one so
yeah I'm pushing it's a little time we
have for this afternoon but please join
me in thanking Paul for his presentation
you